SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI KHAN: So
today what we are going to play
is-- they would like to dedicate
this concert to the world
peace and harmony.
And the opening first
piece-- the two songs
which we are going to
play they are almost
like Indian national songs
and great favorites of Mahatma
Gandhi, the father of nation.
[HINDI] and [SPEAKING HINDI].
They're both songs that
have beautiful message
and the melodic structure
is so appealing.
So we would like to play that.
And before that, I
would like to introduce
all the musicians
sitting on the stage.
Anubrata Chatterjee.
[APPLAUSE]
And my elder son,
Amaan Ali Khan.
[APPLAUSE]
And two years younger,
Ayaan Ali Khan.
[APPLAUSE]
And they are very happy that
Amaan and Ayaan's mother,
Subhalakshmi is
in the auditorium.
She's the first guru
of Amaan and Ayaan.
[APPLAUSE]
[INDIAN MUSIC]
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD
ALI KHAN: [INAUDIBLE].
[SLOW SITAR MUSIC]
[DRUMS AND SITAR MUSIC]
[FASTER SITAR MUSIC SOLO]
[APPLAUSE]
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI
KHAN: Thank you so much.
The next item is a song
written and composed
by Rabindranath Tagore.
He in fact composed many songs
on different kind of ragas.
As a tribute to him,
I made a CD that I
played ten songs of
Rabindranath Sangeet
with legendary Suchitra
Mitra, the singer from Bengal.
This particular song is based
on folk music of Bengal.
And it has a beautiful
message, [INAUDIBLE].
Don't keep waiting for
people to follow you.
With your message,
keep walking alone.
[INAUDIBLE], thank you.
[SITAR MUSIC]
[MID-TEMPO DRUM AND SITAR MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI
KHAN: So the concluding piece
is a traditional raga raag desh.
All the great masters,
vocalists, instrumentalists,
they all contributed and they
all express their thoughts,
beautiful thoughts of raag desh.
We'll play this composition
in 10 beats time cycle,
followed by a 16 beats
time cycle composition.
Raag desh.
After this, we will
be very happy to take
some certain questions
some all of you.
And we are all so proud of
you, of this organization.
I'm sure if you Google,
you will find Sarod.
So we will conclude
with raag desh.
And once again, I would like
to say on behalf of all of us,
that we are very happy
and honored to be here
and to share music
with all of you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[SITAR MUSIC]
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI
KHAN: Certainly this
is what Indian
classical music is.
That we don't plan
everything before.
Everything happens one this
stage while we what we play.
I just feel like sharing one
particular style of music.
We have lots of songs
all over the world.
Different languages and
different kinds of messages.
But there was a great [HINDI],
Hasan Amir Khusro who created
[HINDI] and also a singing
style called tarana.
Tarana doesn't
deal with language.
He created a language
of syllables.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN SOUNDS]
And it's very interesting.
So as a tribute to
Hasan Amir Khusro,
I compose this tarana
in raag [INAUDIBLE].
[SINGING]
[DRUMS]
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI
KHAN: We'll play on this now.
[DRUMS AND SITAR MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
[SLOWER SITAR MUSIC]
[FASTER SITAR MUSIC]
[MID-TEMPO DRUM AND SITAR MUSIC]
[FAST SITAR MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Googlers,
another big round
of applause for Ustad Amjad
Ali Khan and his sons, please.
[APPLAUSE]
We have time for a short
conversation with Ustad
and his sons, so if
you have any questions,
you can line up on the mics.
And I'll lead off with
the first question.
So Ustadji, it's such
a pleasure, privilege,
and honor to have you and your
sons perform here at Google.
And at the beginning,
you mentioned
about the guru
[HINDI], the lineage
of learning from your guru.
But in your case,
it was your father.
In your sons' case, the
parents were the gurus.
Can you talk a little bit
about having the guru live
in the house itself and be
your father or your parent?
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI KHAN:
It's the Indian realization
of guru was much more in India.
The surrendered-ness
towards God or guru
was more experienced in India.
And the guru demanded
complete attention,
complete
surrendered-ness And most
of the disciples,
the students, they
worked like a domestic
help in the house.
So a guru was
considered institution.
Now we look for a huge
concrete building,
they are called institutions.
So that is the basic difference.
The lifestyle changed.
The requirements of
people who changed.
And everybody is trying to
reach to the moon and the sun.
But my father, my
guru, often said
that one should be
focused in life.
I can't do everything.
I can't be a Ph.D. and
also play good sarod.
So one has to choose right
in the beginning what
you want to do with your life.
And similarly, I'm sure Amaan
would like to say something.
Ayaan would like
to say something.
So this commitment
and realization.
So we are all humble
representative
of this ancient art Indian
classical music, sarod.
Sarod is a Persian
word which means music.
And we had great
gurus in our country.
All over the world, we had great
sages, saints, philosophers.
But unfortunately, nobody
could [INAUDIBLE] us.
Today we have become such
a ferocious, unkind animal
that the whole world is
afraid of peace, of harmony.
There's a danger for world
peace and harmony in the world.
So unfortunately, when
the education could not
create compassion and
kindness in the human being,
so we are going through
a very bad phase.
And I hope people realize that
we have to share the kindness
and love with our children.
So we must have a-- in
our family-- as you know,
my wife is Subhalakshmi--
we feel connected
with every soul of the world.
And we feel that we
have a common god
and we are the common race.
So I hope people
get this message
and we are able to control
this violence and destruction
for what is happening
in the world.
MODERATOR: Thank you, Ustadji.
And very quickly, I wanted
to hear from Amaan and Ayaan
as well.
What was it like to
grow up in a household
where your parents were
both world class musicians.
What is the pressure like?
AMAAN ALI KHAN: Good afternoon.
It's always, I say
it's a pleasure.
Now I feel it's an honor,
because when you're
much younger, you don't
realize where you're born.
You just feel it's people
are looking at your parents.
And oh, they are popular.
You get that feeling.
But as you grow up, you
realize the responsibilities
that keep growing.
My mother was a very eminent
Bharatanatyam dancer.
She learned from Shrimati
Rukmini Devi Arundale
from Chennai.
And my father comes
from a lineage-- well,
I know where you come, but from
this heavy family of musicians.
So I think it's an honor.
And it is not very easy.
It is difficult.
But as they say, there
are no free lunches.
So you enjoy all the importance,
not [INAUDIBLE] thing.
So really working
hard towards that.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
AMAAN ALI KHAN: Ayaan.
AYAAN ALI KHAN: Good afternoon.
I think my brother's pretty much
covered the emotion that even
I went through.
But of course it was a great
honor and a great privilege
also to just be born in a family
where the language spoken was
music.
The air we were
breathing was music.
And much as I say there was
no pressure, but perhaps
in a sense there always was.
Because as an eight year
old or a seven year old,
even when I would just go
with my father at concerts,
you would meet
people who'd say, oh.
We've heard your
grandfather or your father
and now we are
waiting to hear you.
So that, at some level, it
was all building up inside.
And, of course, my parents have
been made gracious people who
gave us the freedom to decide
as to whatever you want to do.
But then eventually I think
we heard what the heart said.
And I think it was the
right thing for us to do.
And I think then we got
passionate about what
we were doing.
MODERATOR: Thank you, Ayaan.
And Ustadji said you'd like
to hear a little bit from Mrs.
Khan also, so-- you'll have
to have the argument with him.
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD
ALI KHAN: [INAUDIBLE].
MODERATOR: Exactly.
Yeah.
The legendary sons and the
dad right in front of you
performing like this.
SUBHALAKSHMI KHAN: Well, I
think it is not easy definitely,
if I have to be very frank.
But at the same time,
it's an honor and pleasure
to be wife of such a legend and
mother of two very beautiful--
beautiful I don't
mean look-wise.
Beautiful souls.
And they're really
wonderful children.
And they're working very hard,
that much I can say, vouch for.
And I really wish they
are able to carry forth
the tradition of this
family, because they
are in an unbroken chain
of the seventh generation
of continuing the sarod.
So I hope even the eighth
generation will continue,
but I can only wish
them all the very best,
and it has always been
an honor and a pleasure
to be associated
with this family.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Congratulations.
You have done very well.
Now we'll take some
audience questions,
and we'll have time for
a couple of questions.
But after that, Ustadji and his
sons and family will be here
and they'll be signing
books and CDs at the back.
So you can have direct
conversation with them.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
again to be here.
We are very honored.
And Mrs. Khan, I can
assure you, your sons
are beautiful look-wise too.
So this question is both
for you, Amaan and Ayaan.
As technology is improving and
YouTube is becoming pervasive,
what do think is
role of technology
in spreading sarod or Indian
classical music as such?
And what can a
company like Google
do to help you spread the word?
AYAAN ALI KHAN: No, I think
it's a wonderful time.
That we all are a part
of social media today
and all the networks which
propagate and promote
arts and culture.
So I think it's
wonderful that now
any musician or any
creative person--
or anyone for that matter--
can post what they are doing.
And I think we have
a lot of content now
which is very easily available,
especially for a younger artist
if he wants references.
If he wants to hear
all the great masters.
Everything is so
easily available.
And the beautiful part is
now even most artists now
have-- you can directly access
them because of this medium.
So I think it's wonderful.
It's great.
Not many people extremely
savvy yet, but then one
is trying to keep up.
But I think it's
just a wonderful time
for just reaching
out to people now.
AMAAN ALI KHAN: Google
can help starting with us.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming, again.
So my question was on
similar lines and technology.
So I see that [INAUDIBLE]
has a Twitter page,
has a Facebook page.
He also updated today.
He is coming to
Googleplex and stuff.
But as the audience is changing,
like the generation shifts,
how do you see a change
in appreciation of music
from people, from
the audience you get?
Like as the generations are
becoming younger and younger.
SAROD MAESTRO AMJAD ALI
KHAN: It's very rare
to see people sitting
and performing nowadays.
Everybody's dancing
and standing.
So that is the basic difference.
But we must protect
our tradition.
We must protect our identity.
So we'll have to
collectively make
an effort to protect
our tradition.
Every country's tradition,
every country's identity.
It's very important.
Because I feel that God
has given identity of music
to every country through
a line of melody.
In India, we have
so many states.
Rajasthan, Gujarat, Punjab.
Through a line of melody, you
can make out it's Gujarat.
It is Rajasthan, or-- so that
is great blessings of God.
And what music we have
this-- we don't read music.
We don't write music.
But we improvise and everything
is-- whatever we performed,
we can't repeat.
Only Google can show to the
world what we did today.
But we can't give
identical concert.
So it was especially meant
for all of you today.
And so we must carry and
we must provide and promote
our traditional art.
Because life is
not entertainment.
They are laughter
shows on the TVs.
It's fine for few moments.
But life is not just
entertainment or laughing
shows.
So a tradition, the
European music, the way
they have preserved
Beethoven, Bach, Mozart.
And I am also now
enjoying composing
for orchestras and
Philharmonic orchestras.
My work with the Scottish
Chamber Orchestra, [INAUDIBLE].
So this is the way
that musically we
can talk to each other.
We can collectively
try to give the message
that we are the same race.
We love each other.
If we can't help
each other, don't
try to destroy each other.
So I think we must
preserve our identity.
And there are so many talented
among Amaan's and Ayaan's
generation.
There are so many
talented musicians
in south India and north India.
All over the world.
So I think music has played
a very important role
to connect the world.
And music will continue
to connect the world
through peaceful
music, appealing music.
MODERATOR: In
closing, again, I want
to say a big thank you to
Subhalakshmi, Anubrata, Ayaan,
Amaan, and [INAUDIBLE]
Amjad Ali Khan.
Googlers, please join me
in saying a big thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]